welcome to our British Beauty - this is
where the makeup magic happens
led by Neil Young who is absolutely
major who does a lot of backstage work
and so that's where I know him from and
literally he's giving everybody I mean
just look how gorgeous look at you
supermodel when you saw the casting call
what was it that made you enter I think
really your description on your
Instagram right and because I think
Apple so has a different enough from BPM
what it should be and that iPhone Cecil
[Music]
British Beauty means everything is kind
of like incorporating everyone and
everyone's allowed to represent having
the freedom to express who you are
within Britain without worrying about
whether and one asking which beauty is
diversity or gender it's all types of
people different colours is no real
standard definition
and then on set obviously different
color armors different lighting we're
changing the lighting for every look
I mean check out the fabulosity
below so far it's looking phenomenal so
much more gorgeous than even I had
imagined we have really high hopes of
the shoot we've got a ton of really
experimental creative ideas and what
I've been really delighted about is how
much everybody in but all the models
have really embraced it and they're
really up for trying things and they're
all fantastic in front of the camera
[Music]
so fine like everything that getting my
makeup done have it is going to go down
in history and I think there's nothing
more beautiful than seeing a confident
woman no matter how how she looks in
kind of feel there's greater from this
beauty it's something that you can
always carry in your eyes for graduates
of what you're wearing
okay Lisa walk with it we'll spend the
summer with buy that baby
[Music]